like its predecessor the evil within to
is a game entrenched in the survival
horror genre which means you've got to
be constantly mindful of resource
management and your overall performance
the game can be tough for newcomers
especially if you aren't used to the
particular level of combat skill and
observational habits the game demands to
help you take on the evil within twos
tense challenges and horrifying
monstrosity here are the things we wish
we knew before starting supplies are
limited in the evil within - that's why
it's essential to scour every nook and
cranny of the environment for whatever
you can find break every single box you
see you'll never know what sort of items
might come out of a broken box dive into
some trash cans for some spare weapon
parts and punch vending machines up to
three times for a reward like 300 green
gel or gun parts unlike the first game
the evil within - has a larger emphasis
on exploration as a result there are
more opportunities to branch out and
find supplies but even cooler is the
optional spooky encounters deal
uncovered visiting a seemingly normal
house might lead to a hide-and-seek
situation with a terrifying ghost and a
sweet reward so take your time to
explore whether it's to get a better lay
of the land or satisfy any curiosities
you might have in your desperate search
for supplies make sure to keep an eye
out for any hidden enemies or
environmental traps nothing is worse
than bowling a third of your health
because of an unexpected enemy lunging
at you pay better attention to your
environment and route out any looming
threats before they can get the better
of you you're gonna have to make some
tough choices when it comes to what
upgrades to pick they're all useful but
I highly recommend picking up bottle
break as soon as you can now when an
enemy grabs you if you have any bottles
on hand you'll smash them on the head
with it breaking free a useful tactic
when in a tough situation
certain environmental hazards can be
used to your advantage if an enemy is
standing in a pool of water shoot it
with a shock bolt to stun them or try
kicking over an oil drum luring some
enemies over to it and then shooting the
oil to set the ground ablaze here are
several quick little tips you can take
advantage of if you hold down the left
trigger while opening a door sebastian
keeps his gun out it's an easy one to
forget but press the right bumper while
moving back to do a quick 180 after
you've marked an objective on the radio
once the bastion puts it on its belt you
can still see the number move meaning
you can just look at that rather than
keep pulling out the radio those are
some tips that we found key to helping
us survive the world of the evil within
q if you have any tips of your own leave
them in the comments and make sure to
check out our full review thanks for
watching
[Music]